relocate refugees that was the main
message in today's state of the European
Union address European Commission
President jean-claude Juncker officially
laid out a proposal that would relocate
160,000 refugees throughout Europe from
where they currently reside in Italy
Greece and Hungary this is not the time
to take flight it's a time of humanity
and human dignity under this plan
Germany France and Spain would take a
majority of the relocated refugees the
compulsory quotas are determined by each
country's GDP population unemployment
rate and the number of asylum
applications that's already processed
with that total number to relocate
160,000 that's still only four percent
of the nearly four million refugees
currently living in Lebanon Turkey and
Jordan younger also proposed to scrap
the Dublin regulation which says that
refugees can only apply for asylum in
the first European country they reach
but getting all EU countries on the same
page is not easy we must be mad to take
this risk if we want to help genuine
refugees if we want to protect our
societies we must stop the boats coming
Germany and France have been pushing for
the stricter quota
although German Chancellor Angela Merkel
says it should be even higher her
country has said it could take in
500,000 people every year for several
years Italy and Greece also support the
compulsory quotas since so many refugees
escaping across the Mediterranean land
there but several Eastern European
countries have been resistant Hungary's
anti-immigrant prime minister opposes
any sort of relocation plan even though
his country would only be required to
take in 827 refugees hungary has
actively been build
a fence to keep refugees out the Prime
Minister the Czech Republic said the
quotas are not a good solution and
slovakia's Prime Minister called them
irrational and both Slovakia and Poland
that previously said they would
cherry-pick only Christian refugees to
accept into their countries meanwhile
the Turkish Prime Minister slammed what
he called Europe's ridiculously low
shares in the resettlement rate Turkey
has taken in 2 million refugees the most
of any country of course the European
proposals don't include the millions of
refugees in transit or temporarily
residing in other countries like Lebanon
and Turkey and with thousands of
refugees facing scenarios like this
daily and with no end in sight with the
wars in their home countries would the
European proposal even be enough